-Welcome back.
I'm here with Kerry Washington.
Oh, we love you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Unprisoned" on Hulu
this Friday.
-Yes.
-Kerry and I -- We're gonna play
a fun, new game called
"Mmm-Hmmm-Hmmm."
-"Mmm-Hmmm-Hmmm."
♪♪
-♪ "Mmm-Hmmm-Hmmm" ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright, so, --
"Mmm-Hmmm-Hmmm."
Here's how -- Thank you
for always being a good sport.
Here's how this works.
We're going to each
take turns reading
what's on one of these
blue cards.
The other person has to guess
what they're saying.
The trick is, we can't open our
mouths or move our lips.
Kerry, are you ready for
"Mmm-Hmmm-Hmmm"?
-I've never been more
ready for --
-Alright, I will go first.
I will go first.
-Oh.
-"Mmm-Hmmm-Hmmm."
-I mean, it is
International Women's Day.
-Here we go. That's true.
Yeah, you're right.
I'll let you have the next.
-Oh, okay.
-I'll let you have
next one, yeah.
I'll go first
to show how it's done.
Here we go.
-Okay.
-This is -- Alright.
How are we going to do this?
It's "Movies" -- okay? --
is the category.
-Okay. Okay.
-So think of a movie.
-Okay.
-Yep.
-Yes.
-Alright, ready?
-Yeah.
-[ Humming ]
-"Hot Chocolate Nutcracker."
[ Laughter ]
-"Hot Chocolate Nutcracker"
is not it, but close.
-Okay.
-[ Humming ]
-Yeah.
Planes -- Airplanes --
Airplanes and --
Airplane --
Oh, "Top Gun: Maverick."
-Yes, you're right!
[ Dinging ]
That's exactly how you do it!
♪♪
"Mmm-Hmmm-Hmmm"!
That's how you play
"Mmm-Hmmm-Hmmm."
-So good!
-Alright, here we go!
-We're good partners.
We can do this. Come on.
-Okay, okay. Okay.
Category is, again, "Movies."
-"Movies." I got this, Kerry.
-Okay, ready?
-Yep.
-Okay.
[ Humming ]
-Oh.
-[ Mumbles ]
-Ooh!
-Ooh! Sex -- Sexy -- No.
Oh! "Elvis?"
-Yes!
[ Dinging ]
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
"Mmm-Hmmm-Hmmm."
-Yeah.
-"Mmm-Hmmm-Hmmm."
"Mmm-Hmmm-Hmmm."
Oh, yeah.
-Okay, let's go.
-"Mmm-Hmmm-Hmmm."
-Okay.
-Oh, I love this. I love it.
That was great. Good job.
Okay, here we go.
-It's a good vocal warm-up.
-It really is.
Alright,
we're changing categories.
-Oh, dear.
-This is "Popular Phrases."
-Okay.
-This is a popular phrase.
-Sure.
-Okay, ready?
-Okay.
-[ Mumbles ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Humming ]
-No, she didn't.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crash ]
-[ Humming ]
-Oh! What is that?
[ Humming ]
-[ Humming ]
[ Laughter ]
-What is it?
-Wait, wait.
-Make him do it again.
-Don't make me do it again.
Don't. He's cruel. He's cruel.
[ Meowing ]
[ Laughter ]
Cheating a little bit.
[ Both humming, meowing ]
-Do you know what it is?
-[ Humming ]
-You do? What is it?
-I'm not telling you.
-Come on!
-Why can't you tell her?
What? Cat got your tongue?
Yeah!
-Oh!
[ Dinging ]
♪♪
-Alright.
-That's popular?
-I don't know.
It's not a popular phrase.
-That's not popular.
-Alright, here we go.
-That's, like,
popular to my grandmother.
Okay.
-"Popular Phrase." Mm-hmm.
-This is actually really easy.
-Okay.
-No presh.
-Yeah.
Yeah, thanks. So pre--
-[ Humming ]
-Peter Piper picked a peck
of pickled peppers.
[ Dinging ]
Come on!
-Bam!
-That's how you do it!
That's how you do it!
♪♪
Good job.
That's my partner, right there,
Kerry Washington!
Stream all episodes of
"Unprisoned"
this Friday on Hulu.